you're with the daily climate show for
the next 10 minutes coming up
the new Chancellor scales back energy
help but could another U-turn be on the
way
with nuclear energy the solution to the
climate crisis we explore how
radioactive waste could be stored and it
involves going deep to ground
protests from just stop oil demanding an
end to new government oil and gas
licenses
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes
happening to our world and interrogate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now we'll start today
with the government's energy price
guarantee originally put in place for
two years now this was all to limit the
price suppliers could charge you for the
energy you use well today the new
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt announced that
the price cap on our energy bills will
only be in place until April next year
I'm joined by Sky's climate change and
energy correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
thanks for joining us so the first
question then where do we stand with the
government's energy policy then well it
was a bit of a blink and you'll miss it
line but in there I think was a real
hint at what's about to happen Jeremy
Hunt said that the energy price
guarantee will be better structured to
better incentivize Energy Efficiency and
and if you think about it that's exactly
the opposite of what Liz trust wanted to
do you'll remember when she announced it
the first time around she steadfastly
refused to ask the British public all
businesses for that matter to use less
energy she was worried that that would
impact growth well at the time
campaigners opposition MPS even people
within her own party were saying this is
a tremendous missed opportunity if you
reduce demand you're going to alleviate
pressure on people's wallets you're
going to reduce the need for foreign
energy import and you're also going to
be able to do something about tackling
climate change still she refused against
the advice of her own climate change
advisors but now Jeremy Hunt has done
the shifting for her or appears to have
done anyway what we don't know is
exactly what that will look like in the
chaos of this particular political
moment does Jeremy Hunt mean that
actually what he's going to do is just
wait for the price Rises to impact
people's use of energy and reduce it
kind of organically it's unlikely to
mean an extra spending or of any
description on for example a home
insulation program but I think what
certainly is in the Chancellor's mind is
that he is going to need to keep the
lights on this winter and reducing
energy demand is a good way to do that
and so we may yet see a
government-backed Energy savings program
aimed at the British public coming in
the next few months so so interesting
and also today then the first Minister
was using this opportunity to talk about
Scotland
becoming independent from the UK but
also her aims for Reliable low-cost
energy for Scotland yeah this is
Nicholas sturgeon laying out what she
said is her refreshed vision for the
case for Independence and how to harness
arguably Scotland's greatest asset
commercially speaking anyway which is
the North Sea have a listen to what she
had to say
oil and gas is a declining asset and Our
obligation to the planet means that we
must move away from fossil fuels as
quickly as possible but oil and gas
can't be switched off overnight so
Scotland could benefit from these
revenues for some time yet if we invest
remaining oil revenues and use our new
borrowing Powers responsibly and for a
purpose we can invest up to 20 billion
pounds in the first decade of
Independence
and not very veiled dig there at this
government for failing to invest at the
requisite scale
and Pace to really drive along the
renewable energy transition you know I
think Aberdeen might have something to
say about suddenly becoming the Net Zero
capital of the world it might argue that
there's already been plenty of work
going into that particular project
already and I think the British
government might also say we have long
had an ambition to become the Saudi
Arabia of wind there is plenty of
ambition and scale at work in the North
Sea but it is a complicated project and
they've had to move quite carefully
absolutely Hannah thank you so much
fascinating thanks for keeping us up to
date on that one well let's take a look
at some of the days other climate news
now and Australia's prime minister has
won the situation in flood hit areas of
the country remains very dangerous
October is usually the start of wildfire
season in New South Wales Victoria and
Tasmania but instead they're enduring
record and near record flooding so
Victoria is the worst affected state
where 34 000 homes are at risk of
becoming inundated or isolated
there is further rain expected later uh
this week so it remains a very dangerous
situation there are over a hundred
Australian Defense Force personnel on
the ground in Victoria providing support
with evacuations with sandbagging with
some of the early stages of the cleanup
environmental protesters forced the M25
to close today after climbing up the
Dartford crossing bridge Essex police
closed the road after two people from
just stop oil climbed the 84 meter high
masts the closure caused more than two
hour delays and they expected the bridge
to be closed for some time the groups
say they're demonstrating against new
government oil and gas licenses
new data has been released today to
provide new insights into the Public's
recycling habits to Mark the start of
recycling week 2022 now the research
found that people over the age of 55 are
most clued up whereas Generation Z were
most confused when it comes to recycling
with glass being the number one
contaminant with many households
mistakenly adding old broken drinking
glasses to their recycling
now Scotland's national parks have
entered into a 70 million pound deal to
fund the restoration of damaged peatland
by selling carbon credits to
corporations the new fund is being
managed by a private firm Revere with
the aim of attracting private Finance
into nature restoration and farmers and
landowners can access the money to
create a carbon credit business turning
portal damage peatland from a source of
carbon dioxide into a carbon store
and finally to a UK exclusive we're
talking nuclear energy the UK government
are keen on it as a solution to the
energy crisis but there are serious
concerns about how the mounting volume
of radioactive waste will be stored well
in Finland the world's first nuclear
necropolis for storing waste is taking
shape 500 meters below ground skin uses
science correspondent Thomas Moore
traveled deep into the tunnels with the
UK agency responsible for finding a
solution he sent this report
on finland's West coat they've been
generating nuclear power for more than
40 years temporarily storing highly
radioactive waste in shielded bunkers
so we are going on the ground
now for the first time anywhere in the
world they're going to bury it more than
400 meters underground the Bedrock is
1.9 billion years old and studies
suggest it's an ideal nuclear tomb
The Rock itself are like in the whole
area in Finland
as in general is very stable we have old
truck we don't have continental plates
earthquakes seismicity things like that
these tunnels will eventually stretch
for 40 miles and hold six and a half
thousand tons of spent nuclear fuel once
full they'll be back filled and the
whole complex sealed in while the
radioactivity safely decays
this is being built to last 100
000 years it is an extraordinary time
span go back that long and it's a period
of ice and mammoths and woolly rhinos
and modern humans hadn't even set foot
in Europe but that's the kind of time
scale that's required when you're
dealing with nuclear waste the waste
will be packed in double layered metal
canisters slotted into holes bored in
the floor of the tunnels they'll be
swaddled in the same absorbent material
that's used in cat litter multiple
barriers that are designed to keep
radioactivity locked in we can look in
if you come to this site so the boss
says such deep disposal is far safer
than leaving nuclear waste on the
surface
on the surface the interim storage needs
active measures from humans it needs to
be building needs to be heated
spend fuel must be cooled it must be
there must be security around it
if you look at generation forward you
cannot really
see that that kind of an arrangement
would be risk risk-free enough experts
from Britain and elsewhere are watching
finland's progress for possible sites
for burying the UK's ways to being
shortlisted in Cumbria and Lincolnshire
so we have 70 years worth of waste in
the UK that's already accumulated from
energy production defense industrial
processes and it's not going anywhere
unless we do something with it that we
have to take action to make sure this is
managed responsibly in Finland winning
over local people has been as important
as the engineering urioki is just 10
miles away but the nuclear industry is a
big employer and the mayor says support
for the waste site is high they know
nuclear and final disposal in this area
much much more than for example in the
areas we doesn't have a nuclear power
plants and and that trust has developed
during four decades Finland is decades
ahead in finding a solution for its
nuclear waste
there is a growing consensus that the
260
000 tons piled up worldwide can't be
left for future generations to clean up
Thomas More Sky News in Western Finland
well with just 20 days until the United
Nations climate change conference in
Egypt how will we make the transition to
Net Zero it will certainly be on the
agenda of course as the energy crisis
continues so scan the QR code on the
screen now for your complete guide to
cop27 in Egypt
well that's all from us today we'll be
back tomorrow bye
[Music]